I grew up in the late 70s in rural China
during the final years of my country's
pursuit of absolute equality and expense
of Liberty
at that time everybody had a job but
everyone was struggling in the early 80s
my dad was electrician and my mom worked
two shifts in the local hospital but
still we didn't have enough food and our
living conditions were dismal we were
undoubtedly equal we were equally poor
the state owned everything we owned
nothing the story I'm going to share
with you is about my struggles of
overcoming adversity with my resilience
grit and sheer determination no I'm just
kidding I'm not gonna do that to you
instead instead I am going to tell you
talk about today is about a new form of
collective poverty that many of us don't
recognize and urgently need to be
understood I'm sure you've noticed that
in the past 20 years that asset has
emerged it's been generating wealth and
a breakneck pace as a tool it has
brought businesses deep customer
insights operational efficiency and
enormous top-line growth of a sum it has
also provided device to manipulate a
democratic election or perform civilians
for profit or political purposes what is
this American asset you've guessed it
it's data seven out of top ten most
valuable companies in the world are tech
companies now either directly generate
profit from data or empowered by data
from the core multiple surveys showed
that vast majority of business
decision-makers regard data as essential
assets for success we have all
experienced how data is
shifting this major paradigm shift for
our personal economic and political
lives whoever owns the data owns the
future but who's producing data I assume
everyone in this room has a smartphone
several social media accounts and have
done Google search or two in the past
week we're all producing data yes it is
estimated that by 2030 10 years from now
there will be about 125 billion
connected devices in the world that's an
average about 15 devices per person
where order producing data every day
will be producing exponentially more
Google Facebook and tensions come by
revenue in 2018 was 236 billion u.s.
dollars now how many of you have
received payment from them for the data
you generated for them none right data
has immense value but is centrally
controlled and owned you are all walking
raw materials for those large data
companies but none of your paid not only
that you're not even considered as part
of this equation for income so once
again we're undoubtedly equal we're
equally poor somebody else owns
everything and we own nothing sounds
familiar doesn't it so what should we do
there might be some cruising how my life
turned out after that difficult start
things have began to look out for my
family in the 80s the system evolved and
people began to be allowed to own a
piece of what we created people dive
into the ocean or shahi the Chinese term
described those who left stay on
enterprise jobs and start own businesses
private ownership of business became
personal ownership of cars properties
food clothes and things the ignominy
machine start roaming and people's life
began to improve for the first time to
get rich was glorious so in the nineties
when I went to study in Chengdu in West
China many young individuals like myself
were well positioned to take advantage
of the new system
after I graduated from my university I
co-founded my first business and moved
to Shenzhen the brand new special
economic zone they used to be a fishing
village 20 years later Shenzhen has
become a global innovation powerhouse
private ownership was the form of
Liberty we didn't have before it creates
the unprecedented opportunities for
generations motivating us to work and
study incredibly hard the result was
there more than 850 million people rose
out of poverty according to the World
Bank
China's extreme poverty rate in 1981
when I was a little kid was 88 percent
by 2015
0.7% I am a product of this success and
very happy to share that today I have my
own AI business and a lead a very
worldly and dynamic life a path that was
unimaginable when I was a kid in West
China of course this prosperity came
with the trade-off with equality the
environment and freedom and obviously
I'm not here to argue that China has it
all figured out we haven't know that
data is fully comparable to physical
assets it is not but my life experience
allow me to see what's hiding the plain
sight currently the public discourse is
so focused on the regulatory and privacy
issue when it comes to data ownership
but I want to ask what if we look at
data ownership in a completely different
ways what if data ownership is in fact
is personal individual and economic
issue what if in the new destroyed
economy we are allowed to own a piece of
what we create and give people the
liberty of private private data
ownership the legal concept of ownership
is when you can possess use gift passed
on destroy or trade it or sell it your
asset at a price accepted by
you what if we give the same definition
to individuals data so individuals can
use or destroy our data or we trade in
our chosen price now I know some of you
might say I would never ever trade my
data for any amount of money but that
let me remind you is exactly what you're
doing now except you're giving your data
away for free plus privacy is a very
personal and nuanced issue you might
have the privilege to prioritize your
privacy over money but for millions of
small business owners in China who can
get bank loans easily using their data
to gain rapid long approval from a I
powered lenders can answer their more
pressing needs what's private to you is
different from what's private to the
others what's private to you now is
different from what was private when
you're in college or at least I hope so
we are always although often
subconsciously making such trade-offs
based on our diverse personal beliefs
and life priorities that is why data
ownership will be incomplete without a
pricing power by assigning pricing power
to individuals we gain at or to reflect
our personal and nuanced preferences so
for example you could choose to delay
your data for free if contribution to is
in a particular medical researcher
that's very meaningful for you or if we
have the tools to set our behavior data
in a price of say hundred thousand US
dollars I doubt any political group will
be able to target a many play manipulate
your vote you control you decide now I
know this sounds probably implausible
but trends already pointing to a growing
and very powerful individual data
ownership movement first startups or to
creating tools to allow us to take
Bassem control a new browser called
brave empowers user with brave show the
literally call that by aggressively
blocking data grabbing ads and trackers
and avoid leaking data like other
browsers in rich
turn users can take my some bargaining
and pricing power when users open to
accept ads brave reward users with basic
attention token that can redeem content
behind pay wall from publishers and I've
been using brave for a few months you
have already blocked more than 200,000
ads and and trackers and save 2 hours of
my time now I know some of you interact
with your browser more than with your
partners so you should alleys to find
one that's that doesn't waste your time
and it's not creepy do you think Google
is indispensable think again a search
engine is indispensable Google just has
the monopoly for now a search engine
code go doesn't store your personal
information or follow you along with ads
or track your personal browsing history
instead they give all the users the same
search result instead of based on your
personal browsing records in London a
company called digi me offers my app you
can download on your smartphone that
helps to import and consolidate your
data generated by you from your fitbit
Spotify social media accounts and you
can choose where to store your data and
teaching me will help you to make your
data work for you by providing insights
that used to be exclusively accessible
by large data companies in DC a new
initiative called oopsie UB di universal
basic data income helps people to make
money by sharing anonymous insights
through their data for company's neck I
use for market research and whenever a
company purchases study users get paid
in cash and hoopty points to track their
contribution potentially as much as the
thousand US dollar per year per their
expert estimation whoopty could be a
very visible path for universal basic
income in the AI economy further
individual awareness of privacy and data
ownership is growing fast as we all
become aware of this monster we have
unleashed in our pocket I'm a mother of
two preteen girls and trust me the
single biggest source of stress and
anxiety as a parent for me is my
children's relationship with technology
this is a three page agreement my
husband and I make them sign before they
receive the first agreement we want to
help them to become digital citizens but
only if we can make them to become
smarter responsible ones I help them to
understand what kind of data should
never be shared so if you google me in
fact actually sorry if you dot that Gomi
you'll find maybe a lot about me and my
work but you may find no information of
all my daughters when they grow up if
they want to put themselves out there is
their choice not mine despite I insist
that the most beautiful smartest and
most extraordinary kids in the world of
course and I know many people are having
similar conversations and making similar
decisions which give me hope that a
truly smart data rich future will be
here soon but I want to highlight the
Clause 6 of this Agreement it says I
would never ever search any information
online if I would be embarrassed seen by
grandma Donny try it it's really
effective throughout history there has
always been a trade-off between liberty
and equality in the pursuit of
prosperity the world has constantly
going through the circle of wealth
accumulation to wealth redistribution as
the tension between haves and have-nots
break in so many countries it is in
everyone's interest including the large
data companies
to prevent this new form of inequality
of course individual data ownership is
not a perfect nor the complete answer to
this profoundly complex question of what
makes a good digital society but
according to McKenzie a I will add
thirteen trillion US dollar economic
output in the next ten years data
generated by individuals will no doubt
contribute to this enormous growth
shouldn't we at least consider an
economic model that empowers the people
and if private ownership helped to lift
more than 850 million people out of
poverty it is in our duty and we own it
for future generation to create a more
inclusive AI economy that would empower
the people in addition to businesses
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]